Karnov, the fire-breathing Russian, is seeking the lost treasure of Babylon.
He runs, swims, jumps, climbs, and flies through nine levels of gameplay.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. And I'm Joe.
And welcome to 1988, guys.
Are you voting for Bush or Dukakis?
Well, love it. Sorry.
There might be a few coughs on this episode.
I can't say that. I just gave Joan the nastiest-
Yeah, it was such a dirty look.
We had this rule. We had this agreed upon rule.
Nobody was going to cough in the 1988 episodes.
I think Sam's coughed a lot in the last few episodes.
I'm being serious. I thought I earned a cough.
Yeah. Okay. Well, first I just want to address that Sean is the worst defender when it comes to coughing.
I don't cough. That's true.
Ever. Never coughed. It's true. Never coughed.
Write in with who you think is the worst cough for listeners.
Wait, should we all give a cough?
Maybe in the post show? No.
And it doesn't really matter if you're voting for Bush or Dukakis because we know where
the Donnie Darko family stands on that matter.
That's true. That's unfortunate. It's a very great kitchen scene where-
What does the little girl say?
She goes, what's a- How do you suck a fuck?
They put on a frequency that we're not giving out.
Yeah. So if you want to just tune through, if you live in the tri-state area and want to just
go through every single frequency-
They're live for us while we're recording.
Yeah. That's how you'll know. All right.
That's enough silliness. let's get into Karnov
a game made by Data East
and unfortunately
an attempt at a mascot
character here if you can believe it
did you guys get that sense from Karnov
that like he was destined for
bigger things? No
I didn't. I did read that he was
supposed to be a mascot and I also read that he's
in other games.
Oh he's in there I'm sure we always do that
I don't know if a mascot status was
first in my mind
I do like it when these
third party developers try and make one
for themselves like try to force
it to happen.
I remember on the Super NES I played a game called
Arrow the Acrobat.
Yes. I feel like that was supposed to be something.
Absolutely that's like a Crash Bandicoot
Rayman kind of thing where you're like
this is our platforming star and that's like
Karnov just seems like a very weird choice
for those of you that don't know
this game
it puts you in the bulging muscled
fire breathing East Russian
and Exercus strongman
Karnov as you go on a quest
through nine different levels to search
for the ultimate treasure
the lost treasure of Babylon
yeah
and so Sean maybe give me a little
more than that what is like a what is a
normal gameplay loop like in Karnov
you walk to the right
jump and
shoot fireballs at
enemies until you get to the point
on the right where there is a boss that you
fight pretty much the same way
until the boss you actually were
describing Super Mario Brothers
right I mean like you shoot the fireballs
with the fire flower
so I could see that
I think the biggest difference is that
in this game you probably want to
mostly always be shooting the fireballs
yeah there's just enemies coming a lot
yeah and another important thing to note
about walking to the right
you just reminded me that like
there's only one game so far
that moved to the left
right that was Sky Kid
what about Metroid oh yeah
Metroid you just move wherever
yeah that's an exploration game
I'm talking about like
why did you move no also Kung Fu
there was a full level
where you go oh yeah yeah yeah
you would actually move to the left
and then to the right
and then to the left
you were like a zigzag
yeah you were just going up
a zigzag staircase
anyway I think it's time
for first impressions
Sean walk me through
your first thoughts
as you played
the legendary Data East
arcade mascot character
Karnov my first impression
was when I was reading
through the manual and I
it sort of dawned on me
that most games
of this time
I think the stories
are generated by
a game of Mad Libs
that the developers
create because
I think if you take out
all of the proper nouns
this could be
any game's premise
and I
I don't know like the game itself
it's it seemed to be
what a
what a side-scrolling
platformer
wanted to be
but you know I started to play it
some more and had
more developed
opinions later
sure and Joe
I mean my first thought
was that he was he was a very interesting
character you know
definitely unique as far as
game characters
that we've had before but yeah
as playing it
my initial thought
was that
out of the gate
I wasn't crazy
about the way it controlled
but I mean
yeah with a character
named Jinbarov Karnovsky
you know you really can't
my first impression
was like what even is this
on a North American
platform in 1988
like this is so
like Russian
focused it really isn't
though it's just a guy
yeah no but I guess
what I mean is even the design
of the character is just something
that like to me
would have just been off-putting
to the American
audience at that time
and then you
you follow it up with like
he just kind of
like shoots these fire
he just animates these fireballs
in front of him
like where are they
coming from like his stomach
his mouth I think it's his
mouth stomach it's just very
confusing they do describe it
actually now that I look at it in the
manual it's fire
breathing so it is his
mouth but like it doesn't look
like that in the game
and I don't know
I think that's just a weird choice
this is a strong man
I would almost expect like
you're gonna do some hand-to-hand
combat stuff
you know I was expecting
more of a beat-em-up game
with a character
like Karnoff so my first
impression of this game really
threw me off
in terms of what I was
looking for based on like
the manual and everything
and then what I actually got
in the game do we think
though going back
to the
context in which
this game was released you know
it's now 1988
we're nearing
the end of the Cold War
do you think that this was
Data East's
attempt to broker peace
between East and West
I'm gonna take
I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that the Japanese
didn't care oh okay
you know what was happening
they were trying to get involved
you really
don't okay no I get it
Karnoff was definitely
one of the
like brokering pieces between
Reagan and Gorbachev
getting the wall
down and on top
of that Karnoff started
as an arcade
game first
and the
you know there's some
minor differences
that I think we should talk about
right off the bat and that is that
Karnoff in the
arcade version is a coin
eating game because you die
in just one
hit in the arcade
version I can't imagine
playing that game yeah it's like
anything that comes close to
touching you any projectiles
and you're just this defenseless
guy anything that
comes at you one hit
you're dead I played
through the arcade version
and while the graphics are
definitely nicer
as always you know we've come to
expect this in the arcade
versions there wasn't
too much of a difference
between how gameplay functions
that I actually think the NES
version is a competent port
and I think
that the addition of getting two
hits instead
of one hit is a big
upgrade for the NES
so I imagine
a lot of fans of Karnoff
in the arcade if that existed
then when they got their NES
version they probably
weren't like
you know
hardcore about
it and being like oh this
isn't Karnoff real Karnoff
is only one hit
you know sometimes you
get people who like complain about
difficulties in games
and it's like oh there's a
there's a mode
where Yoshi will just fly
you across the map
like why would you want to play that
Mario game and it's
like I don't know
it's like it's not for you
yeah exactly
now I also
find it funny that
even the
home console version in
Japan had it worse
off because they didn't
have unlimited continues
yes and so
we got the hand
holding which I'm
happy with whether or
not you
think that that's too
much like it's
still really
hard this is a
really hard game
it's
really hard
to just try and
not get
hit half the time
yeah a lot of
times projectiles
especially during some boss battles
I'm sure we'll get into later
but like projectiles
are coming at you in a
formation where I
look back and I'm like how
could I have gotten around that
there was nowhere for
me to go and it happened so
slow that you
just have to watch
yourself die
so let's
get into the gameplay and the
first thing I just want
to talk about is the control
of Karnav
the character control is
something we always care a lot
about how you jump
how you move how the stage
functions and stuff like that
for me
this was
apparent within the
first 10 seconds of
gameplay that this
game was not going
to be something I was going to fall
in love with just
because of
the way Karnav controls in
very specific instances with
ledges he
does that thing where like if
you just walk
off the ledge even a
nanometer off
the ledge you
have to forcefully
watch an animation
of him just falling down to
the edge whereas if you would have
jumped you can
watch a fluid jump animation
and control him
the entire time
what's up with
the inclusion of this ledge fall
thing I'm not sure
this seems like
a relic of
much older
games where
I guess it's
punishing you for
not being as intentional as you
should be but other than
that I have no idea why it's
still in these games yeah I think
that it's weird
that like you said that when
you're jumping you can control
that but I also don't
think the jumping is much better anyways
but yeah like
you said if the if you can
control yourself falling while
you're in the jump why
would it's almost
intentional that
you can't control yourself when you
fall off a ledge which doesn't
make any sense
right yeah the
jumping just overall though
falling jumping
anything is just so
floaty and slow to
me that that that was more frustrating
to me I found the
jumping to actually
be a positive side
for the rest of the
gameplay because
because it was
floaty I really
appreciated that because this is a
game that mostly
relies on dodging
attacks because
enemies take multiple hits to
to get through them and so
yeah you're always
spamming your fire
button but you
need to make sure that you can dodge
the enemy's attacks
and so having a
more precise dodge
say something from
like an ice climbers
or a spelunker even
had like a weird
jump having something
that was only like a few frames would
have would have
had me spamming both buttons all
the time like a faster jump
right having a faster jump instead
of a less I kind of appreciated the
fact that they had a floaty jump going
I guess the reason
that it still bothered
me there were a few
instances several
instances where there
was some enemy higher
up or just above me
in some way and I tried to jump to
avoid one attack and
I could see another attack above but you
can't as soon as you
press that jump
button you are going
in the slow elevator
ride up to the top
of your arc no matter what and like I would
run into things up
there that I didn't want I couldn't dodge
because I because I
couldn't control the height of the jump and
it was so slow that I
was just like up there for so long that
things could shoot me like I ran into
that more than one time and that kind
of comes down to enemy placement though
in general right now
now do we think I
have a couple more thoughts on on
movement itself sure
sure but my
complaints are more
with like again I
think that I agree
with with Mike on
the fact that
jumping itself feels
all right but I
think that when it
comes to hit detection in terms
where you're jumping
to it's terrible
it's it's really
hard to tell what's
a thing you can jump on and what's
a situation in which
you're not going to
clip correctly and
therefore land on a
platform I think
that ladders which
you end up using a lot are super sticky
too where you would
think that you'd be able to jump off of a
ladder but you can't
yeah and sometimes I
feel like you can't get to the top you
can't get to the top
means that you've hit
the top of the screen
I think right because
Karnov needs to stand
on the top of the
ladder so they won't
cut him off yeah so I
mean I just wanted to
expand a bit more on
movement and I mean
since we're talking
about movement in
depth we also have the
duck in this game as
another form of cover
but it's not really a
duck he kind of just
takes a knee right
it's like a little bit
like a pixel lower on
sort of like ducking
I mean if I ducked I'd
probably just go down to
that level except I
wouldn't have as big of
them of like a six pack
yeah and it's weird
because the the enemies
in the game are all
sorts of weird stuff too
I mean we have sword
wielding monks dinosaurs
hopping fish men
gargoyles tree monsters
you name it they're in
this game but they also
are mostly projectile
based characters too
yeah and that just seems
like a strange choice of
like it was really
stupid when you know
there's the there's the
water level and then I
see what looks like a
piece of seaweed and then
it shoots a fireball like
everything shoots fireballs
whether it's a lion tamer
or a piece of seaweed I
don't get the design in
that aspect at all yeah
again another thing I
think would have benefited from like even
just having a couple characters that just like
walk from enter stage
right leave stage left you
know it's like just having
things that are more like
I'm not constantly trying
to dodge it almost
like a shmup platform
right like every encounter
is like a shootout yeah
and I saw a strategy
online which I guess I
kind of use subconsciously
anyways that anytime an
enemy appears to just
walk to the other end of
the screen so you can shoot at him without
getting anywhere near like you might as well just
oh the projectiles your
projectiles will carry that
far yeah I mean as long
as they're I guess I
didn't really test it I I
stayed a middle distance
from every single thing
in the game I stayed at
a distance that felt
comfortable so this way I
could anticipate because some of them are throwing
at you know objects as
large as boulders at you
and so you have to kind of
be you can't be like up in
your face with them because
they're gonna take you those are the words on a
hit so you have that but
then also at the same time
like you don't want to I
feel like you don't want to
leave yourself unguarded from
a second attack so that's why
I kind of like like being in
the middle of any
particular stage because the
screen scrolls with you so I
like being in the middle is this way I had like kind
of complete coverage yeah
again like mentality yeah
of like my blind spots right
and I think you know the
game is the game is
punishing at first to to
people who try to rush
through it you do have to
take down like every single
enemy as as they come up
you really there's a there's
there's certainly some
examples of enemies you can
skip you know if you're on
a different platform from
them you don't have to deal
with them for the most part
but for the for a good
majority of the game you're
kind of just like walking
encountering an obstacle
getting over the obstacle
and then you know there's
these fun moments where like
you know use your power ups
to solve this puzzle thing
and it's like this is not a
puzzle like this is like you
either have that power up or
you don't yeah so speaking of
the enemies I think we should
talk about enemy placement
since that was such a big
thing that we left a note of
on 87 and so something I'd like
to kind of follow up with in
88 not that like this game
wouldn't take any cues from
87 games pretty much just
going to be an 87 game at
this early on point but is
this a good example of a game
that strategically places the
enemies it seems like they
are in locations I'd say it is
an example but I wouldn't say
it's a good example it's
definitely putting putting
them in places on purpose but
I wouldn't say that it is the
the optimal placement it's a
step up it doesn't feel like
you can easily strategize
like okay there's not strategize but just like
learn like this is when this
enemy comes to get like the
muscle memory of it it's more
just feels like just shoot
everything as fast as you can
yeah yeah and when you have
like when you have a gargoyle
to deal with that seems like
enemy placement works more in
that favor because that's a
relatively still enemy in the
game but then you have like
those ostrich skeleton warrior
thing you know it's like a
skeleton riding an ostrich and
it like runs across the screen
yeah like those things it's
almost like you know don't
even bother thinking about how
you're gonna place them if
you're just going to have them
enter as soon as the screen
scrolls their their existence you
know because then it's it's not
timed to anything so it's just
more like oh we hit that
specific spot in the stage level
so just make just send the
enemies right yeah it's more like
they're placing spawn points
where it if you don't you don't
defeat a screen it just you have
to get through it before they
respawn right yeah that is true
there are even those those gold
statue men that just appear you'll
be on a screen it'll appear like
right now it seemed like a random
moment no warning and then if you
don't beat them in like a second
they turn into like something else
but if you die yeah if you die you
will realize that they actually are
spawning in the same place it's
just yeah poorly planned it's just
there's no way of seeing it coming
it's like they almost you know
imagine in the arcade version if
there's only one hit you just get
hit because you happen to be where
an enemy spawn right yeah I don't
think that that sounds fair there
was a there was a segment in the
game where it's just I think it's
not a secret because it's just a
bunch of K marks which I guess we'll
get into later but you go I go down
into this little cave thing and
I walk past the point and then the
I the guy or the gold guy that
we're talking about he looks like
something on us out of earthbound for
some reason in my head yeah and
you're thinking of those like silver
UFO guys yeah exactly yeah so I
passed the point and then he spawns
behind you and that's a dead end on
the other side and so I think it's
just there to be a trap yeah because
you can't escape it I ran into that
exact same thing yeah you can kill it
but it's just it's really ready for
it and and it's it's clever game
design when you're warned about these
kind of things and you're also like
seeing these things commonly placed
and learning from your mistakes it's
not clever game design when it's like
all of a sudden this one thing
happened to me this one time now it's
like there's no rules yeah there's no
rules in Karnoff yeah you just kind of
like like we said the whole thing even
when you move between levels and it's
nice to get a water level and a flying
level but nothing changes in those
stages enough that like makes it feel
any different than what your task was
for the rest of the game yeah like I
know in Half-Life to watch out for the
the guys hanging from the ceiling
because I've learned that if I go into
like a dark wet place and I can kind of
hear some weird movement like oh I
should I should look up but it would
it would be different if they just
sort of drop down from the sky whenever
you were walking through a corridor
like it's just not it doesn't feel like
you're you're meeting a challenge and
learning it just feels like the
developer wanted to fuck with you a
great example we haven't we haven't
had really any sound cues yeah in any of
these NES games so far I think that'll be
an interesting thing to look out for
because that would have been good for
the gold guys you know like to have
almost this like oh no there's an
alarm or something coming yeah but you
know the closest example I can think
of is Kid Icarus had those Reaper
characters that if they saw you it would
play a different music and then and
other enemies would charge at you it's
not the same thing because it's not a
it's not a warning but it is a warning
now that like now that they've seen you
you're in danger yeah you're in
danger right I like that so while we're
talking about these swimming and
flying stages though I think it's a
little weird that you need the power
up for these things because it gives it
to you immediately so it's like why not
just have always had that yeah you know
if you can only use them in those
stages to begin with if you actually
get if you hack the game a little and
get like you know like use a game
gene or something like that and get the
wings they're actually not selectable
in any other stage but the flying one
even if you have them I feel like it
was it was just their attempt to make
it like more immersive like look at
this cool you've got and that well how
it helps you but yeah functionally
instead of yeah it's like here we gave
you this tool that you can use and it's
not just like this level is different
right you are using it so without without
getting further into the power-ups
though when you got to the swimming
stage did anyone think that kind of
became a mermaid for like half a
second it looks like he's got my
mermaid tail like two mermaid I guess
but yeah merman yeah merman but I
think that I don't know something
about that was really funny to me
and it was less funny when he becomes
like an angel in the flying stage
I thought that was funny too actually
because it's just this big bulky guy
who just got these like angelic wings
floating right and that's when the
game truly doesn't become a shmup in
certain regards because you are just
shooting fireballs at other things
shooting fireballs in on us yeah they
thought they can get away with it but
there's we we can detect shmups like
nobody's business when when you get
attacked in this game if a hit
registers you turn blue which signifies
that you have one bar of health left if
you will to me not the best system to
communicate like danger or or this is
your last shot you'll know it as soon as
it happens like you turn blue and then
you die the next time you get hit but
why not just do a health bar with even
just like two big blocks on the hp uh
you have that whole ui down there in
the bottom you're right um but why
clutter it more i guess i'm maybe blue
isn't the best color weird um you'd
prefer him to bleed i yeah i prefer a
bloodied uh karnoff um but it feels like
they're trying to do something similar to
ghosting goblins where you lose your
armor on the first hit yeah and that i
like to think it's also weird no but i
love something visual i think is kind of
i think we talked about this in the
ghosting goblins episode that's a cool
visual cue to be like you are near
death like you don't have your armor
anymore blue doesn't blue doesn't do
anything here's my head cannon um i think
that uh what when karnoff gets hit by
something he eats it and the blue means
that he's choking on the uh projectile and
level for the rest the level and you know
he's just he's losing oxygen i thought he
was just gonna join the blue man group
do we know if any of them are russian i
think they're all russian spies okay
that's a theory for you to discuss on a
later post show uh stick around for that
in the meantime i think i think it is time
now we we need to talk about the power
ups in the game and that whole system
because if we don't talk about the power
ups we're doing this game uh like a
disservice but also everyone who wants to
play this game a disservice because they
need to know how shitty these things
really are i'd like to start off with the
user interface of the power ups because
it was for a very long time confusing and
then uh when i finally figured out what i
was doing it left me with a big why yeah
it was like more confusing as to like how
someone could have come up with this idea
joe do you want to walk us through how
how it works yeah so you obviously to move
left and right you use the left and right
on the d-pad but also to select things on
this this long menu of of items that you've
collected you use left and right on the d-pad
so if i'm trying to move over to two to the
left i have to be walking to the left and
that's that really sums it up i mean not
much more to it now you can select things
while you're paused oh you can i didn't
know that so you don't have to do the
stutter step okay however um i i understand
that there aren't a lot of inputs on this
controller so some things are going to have
to do double duty um and you can't do
context based because we're not really at
the point where that makes any sense um but i
think that this system would have been much
more well received if it just didn't take
any uh ui input until you were paused
absolutely my point because then if it's
paused and you select something and you
on pause it i can't walk or else right you
can't walk or else you'll select something
else exactly you have to use it immediately
or you can you can choose to use it in the
pause menu as well so you can select and
use oh you know i did notice that you can
because i dropped a bomb by accident in
the pause menu but i never thought of
functionally using that yeah but i think
yeah to sean's point it's such a better
idea to it should have never been turned on
while you're actually playing the game
because it almost feels like a mistake
like they couldn't figure out how to not
program it to function at all times but the
fact that you can pause like let's say in
front of an object that needs to be bombed
pause select the bomb even even press the
select button to have it register and then
as soon as you unpause the bomb is there
that seems like a really effective way to
do like a a menu system for for items
you've acquired just don't have the input be
while you're walking yeah and this is a
much better system stutter step thing or i
like trying to select something and i'm
like all right as soon as i select it i
have to be facing the way i want to face
and shoot it yeah which uh it almost gets
becomes like a math problem after a while
but i think there's just also outside of
like that that clunky user interface there's
just a lack of thought put into these power
ups in general the ladder seems more like a
thing that was added on after they designed
the game and said like oh you know there's
really no way to get up there we we should
just give this guy a ladder i did think the
ladder was was silly at first but like i
actually that was probably one of my
more useful power-ups i thought you're
gonna say favorite power i thought it was
one of the everyone loves ladder but like
you know i thought it was way more useful
i thought it was one of the more useful
right but i'm saying like do you don't
you just think that instead they should
have just had like multi-tiered platforms
that you could jump from one to the other
to get to higher platforms like i i used the
ladder in boss battles even to get to
like the their face level and to dodge items
like i i did do that yeah so you can still
shoot when you're on the ladder right yeah
you can still shoot that is useful uh it's
described in the manual as uh use it as an
option positioned in a high place or to
avoid an enemy's attack so it is kind of
nudging you in that direction i also just i
just thought it was just silly and quirky
and kind of funny i don't know those i like
quirky things in there when they function
and then there's the boomerang which to
me just seems like why would you want
that apparently they're really good for
boss battles but i wasn't having any luck
with them i think it's because they
actually deal more attack power but it
throws one and you have to wait for it
you have to catch it or else it's gone
right yeah which is an interesting idea
but i just not executed that well because
there aren't that many boomerangs in
this game you're probably also trying to
like duck and weave through this boss
battle so by the time you want to use it
again you aren't selected anymore it's
not selected yeah because you've been
inputting left and right over and over i
feel like any extra power that it gives
is kind of offset by the fact that then
you have to pause like you're not even
that you have to like do like a chore to
get back to it that puts you in danger
exactly focusing on that and like you're
you know i don't know i'm sure if you're
good at the game you you can do it but
we're not or at least i'm not but and i
didn't know what to call this one but
the manual refers to it as a clapper uh
it looks like bomb all thing yeah it
looks like i um like a like a ninja star
here but it flashes onto the screen and
kills every single enemy on the screen at
one time except bosses cool but like
again who's who's do where's this power
coming from like what is what is going on
like the the mouth breathing fire thing
is already enough of a stretch for me but
now there's like this item that's in the
game that just summons like a yeah one hit
like dead thing but doesn't work on boss
enemies like well i mean i get from a
gameplay perspective why that wouldn't
work on yeah i'm not saying i'm immersed
or anything that just broke my immersion
but i will say that what is going on
which you just said kind of sums up a
lot of what i was thinking while playing
this game it was very confusing a lot of
things in this game what are the rules
also the manual calls this next item
glasses but it's like a mask yeah i think
it's um that just that just shows you uh
secret items right yeah it's actually i
think this is a great example of a power
up because it the mask will actually blink
on the ui when you're near like other
hidden items or power ups and stuff like
that and i think that like that's kind of a
cool like metal detector style thing i
guess yeah i never used it i didn't either i
didn't even notice it was doing that until
i read the manual and i was like oh i should
probably be looking out for if it's
blinking but i guess if you've collected
what you need it only blinks though when
you have like your cursor on it which you
aren't really keeping track right and you
can't keep track of because it keeps moving
through as you're as you're pressing the
right uh d-pad to keep moving on the stage
i won't go through everything but i think
we do need to talk about as sean mentioned
earlier those k's that are all over the
screen okay what a stupid stupid
idea of a collectible you know mario collects
coins right and that's like that doesn't
make any sense right because it's the
mushroom kingdom and do they even need
currency in a world like this right but
coins are cool it's like they thought
about making it an item in the world this
doesn't even look like an item it looks
it's a square tile that just has a k in it
why would karnov like oh naturally he
would collect the letter k everywhere
sort of like in i forgot which shmup it
was but how all of the pickups were just
other letters oh yeah that was from shmup
yeah shmup the movie and it just seems
like the art department got lazy if it
wasn't it's not even like a cut out k it's
like one square tile
i just you know there's not even a great
incentive there because they're like oh for
every 50 you collect you get a life and it's
like there's unlimited continues it doesn't
really matter to begin with but also like
50 of those things littered all over the
screen is like hell it takes up it takes
up a lot of real estate it really uh you
know we were joking about the immersion
thing earlier but like it just seems so
random that they're placed throughout the
stage when there's like okay there's a
pair of boots somewhere i buy it okay
wings sure k's everywhere like whatever
whatever whatever karnov you know after you've gotten through
the nine stages of the final boss is
actually different than the arcade version
uh in the arcade there's a dark wizard and
that that's high that's like the last thing
of the treasure i should also mention at
this point that in the arcade there is a map
that you are collecting pieces through as
you go to each stage to get the map to the
treasure it's a very complicated story
beat that probably wasn't necessary
yeah you know like i don't think the
nes needed that yeah but at the same
time the nes has like no story going on
here nothing at all the manual just says
you're collecting the lost treasure of
babylon so you're not really sure what
to expect is the final boss it's a dragon
doesn't it in the manual not okay so
thank you for mentioning that because not
only does it say it's a dragon it shows
you a picture of the final fight of the
game in the manual very casually it's not
even like trying to be be like oh you
know like let's just sneak in an image
of the final boss it's actually just
showing him and says here you will
encounter ryu in a deep forest atop the
mountain good luck so i guess the dragon's
name is ryu it's kind of like a dragon
snake like thing but there are dragons in
the thing that throughout the stages that
follow you this one there's like three
windows in this in this mountain that
he just kind of like pops his head out
yeah he's actually one of the like i
don't know easier battles we've had for
final boss i didn't play the final boss i
will admit but but watching it looks very
underwhelming yeah it's a head that that's
whack-a-mole yeah essentially whack-a-mole
and as long as you stay in similar positions
for when you know which window it's coming
out of he can only extend his head so far
yeah he just can't reach you wait he won't
be able to reach you so say he comes out
of the left window if you see his head
like because first it kind of just like
shadows out just walk to the right he
let him come out and then just shoot a
couple fireballs he shoots one slow
projectile it's a very big ball of fire
and comparing that just to the to the
clumps of projectiles some other bosses
fought that were like almost unavoidable
just seems like i like that yeah it just
seems like this is like a such an such an
easier battle yeah and we were fighting
dinosaurs as bosses the whole dinosaur
not just its neck and head like this
this guy yeah so i don't know that this
just seems strange but even more strange
is that even though this is a port they
chose to keep the same final boss stage
design as the dark wizard the dark wizard
actually has those same three windows
even though they had to redesign it for
the nes version they chose to not change
anything other than instead of a wizard
which was probably too much for them to
program they chose to just reuse an asset
of a dragon it's too hard to program a
wizard you need to have a very high
spell book to cast the dark wizard i will
say though i like karnav's uh strategy
now that i'm thinking about it no other
hero just doesn't go into the room with
the dragon he just stands at the window
yeah and shoots him from the window don't
go in there that's what it's his turf and
is the is the dragon like guarding the
treasure of babylon i think so
treasure well we'll never know we'll
never know because if you if you defeat
ryu the uh the dragon boss at the end of
the game uh you get a you just get a
congratulations the end screen and then
some credits but no closure i'm like you
don't even get a mention of the treasure
actually so you don't know that you're
trying to collect this treasure so why
didn't the manual the game told me i did a
good job though so why didn't the manual
why didn't the manual just set up the
idea that like oh you know karnav was
hanging out in town and all of a sudden
this dragon at the top of the mountain
started casting down evil enemies and
it's your job to get to the top of the
mountain and kill ryu the mystical dragon
exactly you don't have that treasure
treasure beat it is interesting it really
feels like a rush like they had they had
to ship it and they were like oh what
can we do for the ending just someone
just got out their keyboard and just
congratulations the end i like to read
it without punctuation to congratulations
the end like it's just really fast we can get
out of here whereas in the arcade
version if you defeat the wizard you
will earn the final piece of the map and
then be presented with a short ending
where karnav finds the treasure so you
don't even get to navigate the map what
is this right there's no like uh you
can now play as luigi there's no moment
like that instead it's just now that
you've collected all the pieces to the
map enjoy this cut scene where karnav
solves the problem that you were trying
to do www.
такую такую www.
такую www.
www www.
And there's only one track in the game, really.
Now, there's a music change as early as the final boss.
The music changes.
That's true.
But I think that the more iconic one is probably the one I've played by now in this episode.
And it's so jolly.
It's weird. And, like, free-spirited.
I don't get...
This is why earlier I said that this was like a Mad Libs game.
Because I don't understand what this circus performer has to do with all of these mythical creatures around him.
Because... So, the setting of these mythical creatures infesting the land is set to a circus track.
It sounds like a circus song.
Which makes sense because he used to be in the circus.
But that makes sense for him.
Not the setting of the game.
Absolutely. And also, like, you know, why not something more akin to, like, Tetris theme A?
You know? Like, something more Russian, at least?
I don't know. That's what I was expecting.
Or I was expecting maybe some, like, desert-style music.
Like... Why the desert?
The first level gave me vibes of, like, a desert...
Desert music.
There's some desert music in Super Mario Bros.
3. Yeah. That is good.
Oh, it's great music. Great desert music.
We just play that. We should play Super Mario Bros.
3. Maybe we will on this podcast.
Yeah, maybe in a couple years.
Guys, Data East is trying to make a mascot here.
And they have failed.
Well, so far.
So far. What do we think about the potential?
Pretend the game was good.
What is the lifespan of Karnov, even if the game is good?
Like, how would he resonate?
Like, would he be a master chief in this early game development?
Well, I guess the question is, what made Mario iconic?
In terms of his character design?
Yeah, that's a good question.
Do you think that Mario is...
Do you think it's the design?
Or do you think it's the fact that he just happened to be in two really good games?
I think it's... It's got to be a combination of the two.
I don't know. I mean, his design is simple, I guess.
That's one of the main things.
But I think if Karnov was in a great game, he's kind of, like, quirky and interesting.
I mean, that might have some sticking power.
I suppose.
I think that there's too...
It's too quirky to become a mascot.
Maybe. Because mascots are generally open-ended enough that they should be able to appeal to everyone.
Yeah. Whereas there's a Russian fire breather.
It's just too much.
It's too much. Yeah. And also, just like, Mario, you can put in, like, any situation in the Nintendo universe,
and it makes sense.
It's like, cool. Mario's doing this now.
He's doing a party? Great.
He's racing carts?
Cool. If Karnov's like, hey, come to Karnov party, right?
It all has to be... That sounds like you'd call the police, right?
Come to Karnov party.
It all has to be, like, under the setting, though, of, like, Russian influence.
Yeah, so everything is just vodka.
Does it, though? There wasn't really any Russian stuff.
There was zero Russian in this game, aside from apparently...
Yeah, you just have to say it in the manual.
I just... Alright, fine.
You at least have to use, like, the world that you've created here.
So, like, you know, skeletons riding ostriches have to be, like, a normal occurring thing.
They have to be the Goombas. There's no rules.
Again, there's just no rules.
There's no rules. There's gremlins in this game, too.
And it's like, okay, that maybe they're, like, the...
You know, who...
Is Ryu really an iconic...
Is he a Bowser? You know, he's not.
Like, they made a lot...
They didn't think a lot through this.
But, again, like, even Mickey Mouse, right?
No video game.
Like, let's not worry about his video games right now.
Just the mascot element of him.
Is it the design, or is it Steamboat Willie?
Like, which one... Well, considering that I feel like most people that like Mickey Mouse tangentially may not have even seen Steamboat Willie.
Well, I guess that's what I mean, though.
It's like, what started...
We're too far ahead of that. I'm only talking about what started the mascotism.
Not, like, what made...
Because now it's, like, Mario, Mickey Mouse, Sonic.
Like, Sonic can make bad games for the next 20 years and probably will.
And has. Yeah, and has already.
Yeah. But it doesn't matter because he's already a mascot.
Like, you can't take him away.
Yeah. I also think...
I mean, it's that whole thing where...
I mean, correct me if I'm wrong, but I'm pretty sure Disney was setting out to make a mascot as well.
So, maybe partially Steamboat Willie, but then all the things that came afterwards...
Sure. Like, I don't remember.
I don't know for sure, but was Mickey Mouse designed as, like, a random character?
And then they were like, oh, he's so popular.
Let's put him in other things.
Or was it like, he's our mascot.
Let's put him in it. I think it was Steamboat Willie was such a big success because it also happened to, like, sync music to the cartoon.
And that was, like, a big deal, I guess, at the time.
But also, it's runtime and things, too.
Went for it because Mickey Mouse was in two cartoons before Steamboat Willie that, like, Walt Disney doesn't want you to know.
Yeah. Plane Crazy and another one.
Jiminy's Journal and Kingdom Hearts didn't tell me that.
In Plane Crazy, he smokes a cigarette.
Oh, man. So, Mickey Mouse. And he looks a little different.
He looks a little more like a mouse.
So, I definitely think that, you know, the design is important.
Absolutely. You know?
And I'm sure that, like, a ton of research goes in as mascots continue.
Yeah. Like, Sonic the Hedgehog was probably much more thought of in terms of design and look.
It was much more marketing focused.
Right. Than, say, like, Mario was even.
You know? Like, Mario was probably more like, look at this.
We came up with this funny idea of, like, an Italian plumber.
How do we make this guy look as cool as possible?
Right. And so, it's amazing that it paid off.
But you could say that, you know, a good game does matter even more because, you know, Crash Bandicoot had a great, like, start out the gate with those first three games.
And it's not like his mascot design is anything, like, amazing.
Right. But you think of him now and, like, you know, there's, like, a...
But that's where I think that there are maybe almost, like, two roads, too.
I mean, granted, like you said, Crash Bandicoot just happened to be an amazing game that, like, got really popular.
But I think, like, there's a simple, overly relatable mascot, like, design-wise.
And then there's a Bandicoot.
Who had heard of a Bandicoot before Crash Bandicoot?
I think that part of it is there's, like, some intrigue, which I think they maybe missed the mark here where it's, like, people have heard of Russian X Circus fire-breathing people.
It's definitely a spectrum, though, because you've got the home runs like Super Mario, Mickey, and...
Minecraft Steve.
And Sonic. But then you have, in the middle, I think that Crash Bandicoot is not a success story in terms of a mascot.
It was forced for a while, but until, like, the remakes, nobody was really itching for a new Crash Bandicoot game.
I'll say, I think that Crash Bandicoot easily could have been a mascot for longer.
I think kind of Sony sort of just slowly stopped focusing on it.
In its...
I think, you know, in the time of the 90s Crash Bandicoot games, Crash was on track to be the Sony mascot.
They kind of, like, let go of it.
Yeah, we're derailing this conversation.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I will say that, like, I actually think it was a very smart decision for Sony to stay out of the mascot race.
Because it's not their thing. Right.
And just to be like, we actually have hundreds of games.
Yeah, we just have good games.
Yeah. But I was going to turn that into, and then you have Karnav at the other end, which is, like, on the same level of Arrow the Acrobat, and I can't even think of the others.
But, yeah, the mascot idea, I think it would be interesting to go into more when we run into more of these games.
Maybe we'll have a better idea of what it means to be a mascot.
Absolutely. I mean, we've only seen the first Castlevania game and the first Mega Man game, and I don't know if I would say that, like, those two are even necessarily, like, the mascots for their respective developers either.
They're just recognizable video game characters in Simon Belmont and Mega Man.
But I don't know if, like, I think Capcom would probably opt for, like, a Ryu over Mega Man.
Maybe. The future, however, is not kind to Karnav.
They still, they push him for a good while.
I don't think he has a mascot anymore.
They might have arguably had some more popular mascots in the future.
But Karnav does stay in the Data East universe.
He's relegated to being a basic enemy in a lot of future Data East games.
A specific example being...
Hundreds of Karnavs?
What? Like, he's just an enemy that has...
Yeah, he's just an enemy that shows up in games.
Yeah. Like, not even like...
Not like a boss.
Just like... Wow. Yep.
Mm-hmm. But in Bad Dudes vs.
Dragon Ninja, which is a game,
Karnav is the level one boss.
Wow. He's the very first boss you fight in the game.
And this version of Karnav is not...
Maybe it's like his son, because this is Kusamochi Karnav,
not to be confused with Jinbarov, Karnavsky.
Oh, son of Karnav.
So, a little different Karnav there.
Karnav is also the last opponent in the original Fighter's History,
which is Data East's fighting game.
You know, everybody needed their own.
Yeah. So, he had Street Fighter, Mortal Kombat, King of Fighters, Fatal Fury is also SNK.
Yeah. But Fighter's History is Data East's fighting game,
and Karnav is the final boss of the game.
So, that's pretty cool. That's like a big step up for him.
And he becomes a playable character in the sequels.
In fact, the next game in the Fighter's History saga,
which would be Fighter's History 2,
is actually called Karnav's Revenge.
Wow. It's just a game called Karnav's Revenge.
What happened? They lost the Fighter's History thing.
With a face heel turn.
And Karnav, yeah, definitely looks evil in this game too,
and much bigger.
I think they went for a Zangief.
Yeah, they went for like a Zangief feel.
Zangief is from Street Fighter.
No, I understand. I'm just looking at you.
No, that's fine. You're just looking a little puzzled.
And you're about to be very puzzled,
because I'm about to rope in a game called Karate Champ
into the sequels and spinoff section.
Does everybody remember Karate Champ?
I do. We got into a fight about how the best part of that game is the backgrounds.
It was great.
The backgrounds are pretty good.
Back in our 1986 days.
Yeah, but you probably won't remember from Karate Champ
is that after you got through a few fights,
which are impossible to say anybody got through,
but if you did get through a few fights,
you would be treated to a bonus round where you would-
Flower Pot. No, not the Flower Pot, so maybe that was a thing.
That was a thing. I'm thinking more of the-
Yeah, they throw Flower Pots at you. I'm thinking of the bowls.
There's a bowl in the game.
You guys are thinking, I know what you're thinking of now,
Urban Champion is the Flower Pots.
No, they throw it from off screen.
Yeah. Okay, maybe it is a bowl.
Okay. It is a piece of ceramicware.
I thought you were thinking of the windowsills in Urban Champion.
No, no, I know what you're talking about.
Yeah. But there's a bowl that you have to wrangle in Karate Champ.
And in Carnival's Revenge, that bowl-
What the hell does this mean?
That bowl appears as a secret boss.
The bowl. A secret boss?
A secret boss.
If you beat the entire game on the normal setting without losing a round.
You fight a bowl. The bowl.
Yeah, like he's gigantic.
Hold on, let me get this straight. You fight a giant bowl.
Guys, I gotta show you the video afterwards,
and I'll link it in the show notes for everybody else.
I even said a reminder to make sure I do that,
because it is a crazy-
He takes up half the screen.
He's gigantic.
A bowl, like a ceramic bowl.
No, the bowl.
The bowl? With horns.
Yeah, the ox, you know?
I don't remember the ox.
Oh my gosh.
Well, good thing I have two videos.
I have the bowl from the original Karate Champ,
and then the bowl from Karnhauser Revenge.
Bowl. Yeah, you're saying it the same way both times or both instances.
Bowl. Oh, this sounds like a barrel roll with Tom Green,
when he's like, a barrel roll?
Yes, Sean, an ox, okay?
It looks like a bowl to me,
so I didn't want to say ox,
because a lot of people on the internet say that it's an ox,
and I don't agree with that.
I think it's a bowl. But I think Sean thought you were saying a bowl of cereal.
Not a bowl. No, not a bowl.
A bowl of cereal.
A bowl. Okay.
Like the thing that doesn't like red.
I see. That's not true.
Space Jam.
Space Jam would have you believe otherwise.
All right. We're getting a little out there,
but unfortunately,
Karnhoff continues to appear in games, okay?
He appears in the alley background of the Neo Geo game Street Slam,
which is a basketball game.
You know it's him,
because he's wearing a shirt with the letter K on it.
Oh, no. That's what he does with those Ks.
He makes shirts. Yeah, he makes shirts out of them.
Textiles. He laminates them onto his shirts.
But there's that.
And then this is the last thing,
and it's a stretch,
and I almost didn't want to include it,
but hey, we're at this point.
We're just talking about bulls and bulls for an hour.
In Shantae and the Pirate's Curse,
okay, do you guys know about Shantae?
Yeah, no. Okay.
In Shantae and the Pirate's Curse,
a ghostly silhouette who helps Shantae
is highly similar to Karnhoff,
and is even implied to be her dead father.
Okay? All right. Not true.
All right? I'm going to link a video.
You guys can make it up for yourself.
But the only thing that they have in common
is that Karnhoff talks about, like,
fighting a gremlin.
He talks? Yeah.
Well, sorry. I'm saying Karnhoff,
but just like Shantae's father,
who's dead, who's a ghost,
talks about fighting gremlins
and getting over a tree,
and that's something that you do
in the arcade game of Karnhoff.
His theme music is also kind of similar
to Karnhoff's theme music
in the game that we just made fun of,
and he has one line about a ladder.
And people are like, You know what?
It's him. It's gotta be. He loves ladders.
Karnhoff loves ladders.
I'm with you, buddy.
Yeah, so I think that's a stretch.
I'm going to file that under conspiracy theories,
not under confirmed facts.
But one thing I forgot to mention
because we got so caught up in the bowl thing
is that in fighters history,
he appears in all three games, Karnhoff.
That's the move set.
Like, if you watch these videos,
that's the move set I would have liked to see
in this game. You know?
Yes, there's the fireball breathing,
but that's like a special move that he does.
For the most part,
he does some really cool grappling things
and punching and kicking
that the NES game could have used that stuff,
I think for sure. I think that that wasn't...
See, I see this game as a direct follow-up
to Mega Man
as just how you can get all those elements wrong.
So, you know, Mega Man doesn't have any physical moves.
It's just shooting stuff.
So, I just like that idea.
I like that idea too
because we went over a lot of rules in Mega Man
and they followed them all,
but they've done them all so poorly
that it doesn't matter.
Yeah. All right, guys.
I think with that in mind,
it is now time for the Essential Games List.
Okay, it's the first game of 1988,
so don't feel like you have to make this essential.
I know you guys are feeling pretty strong about it.
That's a relief. Joe, since you seem to be relieved now,
would you mind telling us
how you feel about Karnov as an essential game?
I don't have too much more to say.
I don't think it's essential.
But the biggest thing right away,
barring it, is the way it controls for me
and the way the enemies come in and stuff.
I mean, all the other stuff is kind of icing on the not essential cake.
But yeah, I mean,
it wasn't the worst game we've played.
I can say that. Great.
And you know what? I'll take a slice of that cake while you're at it
because I also think that this game is not essential,
mostly for the controls thing.
But I think there's just a,
there's a lack of understanding
in what could have made this game good from Data East.
And this is now like,
I don't even know,
the eighth or ninth game from them
that we're just straight up rejecting.
So they really need to,
they just need to chill for a second
and just think about it.
Now that gets into a whole conversation,
of course, about whether game companies even care
if the games are good or not at this point,
as long as they sell, right?
Like if you're in a limited market
where only a certain amount of games
are coming out each month,
you have a great amount of the share
in what's available to anybody.
So I'm sure a lot of it just went into
like making sure that like
the back of the box looked cool enough
so that you would buy it.
And then, then later,
you know, like where any kids take a note?
Like, oh, I didn't like Karate Champ.
That game sucked. I'm not going to buy the next Data East game.
I wonder how many people thought about that
because we don't have video game magazines yet either.
But that's a whole nother story.
But I say,
Data East, you're not getting away with this.
We will remember you.
Sean? Yeah,
you guys covered it pretty well.
I think that this is just a,
I don't think that there was any direct relationship
because I think that the arcade game
came out before Mega Man.
But this is just like a shoddy Mega Man to me
in terms of the tools
are sort of like your power-ups in Mega Man
and the shoot first nature of it.
It's just not a fun game to play.
It's too hard for its own good.
It's random. It's janky.
It's not essential.
And there you have it.
Three votes as a no
means that there's no way
that Karnov is getting on the essential games list.
That's going to mean that Karnov will not be
on the essential games list.
And so we start off 1988 0 for 1.
But next week we have Renegade,
which is made by Technos Japan.
So maybe they'll give us something.
Any insights on that?
I also hope it's good.
Yeah, good. I hope it's good as well.
And then we actually have another big game
coming up for if you're looking in the forecast.
Two episodes from now we have Contra,
which I'm sure a lot of our listeners are fans of.
Personally, I've never played a Contra,
so I'm excited.
I just know the Vampire Weekend album, Contra.
So I've aged myself out of this.
What about the anti-government forces in Nicaragua?
Is that what Contra, the video game,
is a reference to? Maybe.
Cool. I'm excited to do some anti-stuff.
I am anti-stuff.
You've heard it here.
If you have any thoughts on this episode,
be sure to write to us on Twitter,
at NostalgiaCast.
You can let me know all your thoughts
and thoughts on future games.
I'm Michael Espozito.
You can find me on at Espozito Film on Twitter,
and we'll talk to you soon.
What? www.mo такую такую www.mo такую